Hello Freak bitches.
Now speaking of smoking,
good stuff.
How did you get,
how did you find out about DMT and how'd you get involved?
Cause I read something about you having these positive DMT experiences.
Wow.
How strange is it reading about,
you know,
this massive bodybuilder now getting into psychedelic drugs while um,
and speaking openly about it that first time I did the Ios
that on in Brazil I met my wife who was outside.
She lived in Brazil.
So we went to out to the Amazon and then,
but this was like
10 years ago,
you know,
so people weren't really not like now people know what I,
Alaska is because so much information out there yourself talking about I'm
talking about is,
it's a ton of stuff on the Internet.
It wasn't so much then,
but I heard about it and I heard about this.
It's a life changing experience and all that stuff.
So we were out in Brazil and we've got this guide and ask him for Io Asca and
he's like,
bring me these two balls of brown stuff.
I don't even know to this day if it was really why Alaska,
but I just got really sick and then see any great revelations apart from I got
this thing in my head,
stop poisoning herself.
Well the night before I'd been out drinking and getting drunk and everything.
So you know,
that was my experience with that.
Then a friend of mine out here in California,
actually I knew about DMT.
I used to live in Amsterdam and like I read the TMT spirit molecule and all that
stuff.
So I knew about it,
but I had no idea to get the stuff away you can get it from and everything.
So a friend of mine got it.
And uh,
that was my first experience of like
leaving the room,
so to speak,
and the planet.
And then since then I had uh,
some very positive I Alaska experiences,
but with a shaman and do it properly and prepare in like five days of,
you know,
restricted diet and no sex and all these kinds of things you do to prepare.
And also afterwards.
Um,
so DMT is like blow the fucking doors off your perception and realize that this
world we're in is like,
you know,
it's nothing,
it's just a little illusion,
right?
There's so much more outside of it.
Um,
so there was that.
But with the DMT,
I think it's like you got a computer with like so much storage space and you've
got,
it's like a thousand times more than you can retain.
So you see all this stuff and while you're there you're like,
ah,
I know everything.
Yes.
But when you come back,
how much of it can you hold onto your not right?
Uh,
so you've seen it and that's like,
makes you look at everything differently.
What the IOS SCA is over hours.
So I feel like from the Ios or I have to be benefited more.
It was like going through therapy or something cause it was much slower and I
couldn't digest it,
you know?
So,
um,
but doing it with a Shaman,
uh,
I did it with a guy called Gmo,
other relo and he's one of the top guys in the world from Peru.
It comes to Spain a couple of times a year.
So I did it with him and um,
yeah,
it's probably,
I dunno,
it was probably two or three years since I did DMT because I sat down one day
and I said,
right,
I actually,
I fasted for three days before,
so I'd be like just in the zone.
And I said,
right,
I'm going to sit down.
I've got my DMT here,
I've got my vaporizer.
Yeah.
I'm going to fucking smoke as much DMT as I possibly can to like,
like,
you know,
to I go on and pass out.
So I had that experience and since then I just,
I don't feel any need to do it.
I don't think there's anything more I can take from it.
You know,
I've had many people tell me the same thing.
They had such a profound breakthrough experience that they're like,
okay,
I get it.
Yeah.
I had a crazy one in around tooth,
I want to say like 2008 or nine or some point pat and I took a long time off.
I didn't do it again till like five years later maybe.
Yeah.
It was pretty intense,
man.
I mean the,
the ILS SCA is nice cause it comes in Nice and subtle and you go through hours
of this thing.
But DMT is like last time I did to feel very anxious when you'd like,
like it's almost like you're leaving your body and the [inaudible] and you know,
so you get that bit of anxiety,
but once you go,
oh yeah,
yeah,
that's cool.
But if you've done it more than one time in a day,
like multiple times in a night,
Nah,
I just,
you know,
just blast it as far as it could go.
And that was it.
I've done it several times over the course of a few hours and uh,
you know,
you're more comfortable letting go that way and some sort of a strange way,
but it never gets less alien.
Oh,
he had a,
uh,
I'm not gonna mention his name,
I don't know his name,
but we had an experience with me and my friend a few months ago,
um,
I,
that I've never seen before because usually people take DMT,
they've very calm and sit in the chair and you'd go off and you might start
laughing,
but you know,
you don't move much.
Right.
And this guy,
he just like freaked out,
like it wasn't for 10 minutes with her,
half an hour.
My friend was a former MMA fights,
used to fight with shamrocks and so,
but he know he knew wrestling techniques.
So we had to hold this guy on the floor to stop him from hurting himself because
it was totally freaking out.
So I could see the guy was going through some,
something traumatic from the past.
So today I message him and say,
Hey,
did you ever find out what the guy,
what,
what was that?
You know,
cause it was,
he said,
yeah,
it was from his birth.
What's his,
from his birth when he was born,
he had the cord around his neck.
Oh Jeez.
And he went back and relive this and like,
so that had been in the back of his mind all his life.
Subconscious,
subconscious has a huge effect on us,
but we don't know it's there.
So now he opened that box and let it out and that's gone now,
you know,
so it can be therapeutic.
I thought this guy is like,
wow,
he's going to,
but when it came back,
he was like,
Hey,
I'm like,
you're good.
He's like,
yeah,
I'm good.
I'm like,
do you know what just happened?
He's like,
no.
I said,
good thing.
We filmed at them and then go home and watch this.
I had a friend of freaked out too.
He freaked out.
He threw up,
took his shirt off.
I was running around saying a bunch of crazy shit and then after he came
down,
you know,
we calmed him down and took like 10 15 minutes.
He goes,
okay,
well obviously I'm a work in progress.
I'll never forget that it did it.
Did he know what it was that was
well,
he had a bad childhood for sure.
Everything is like most of our shit is from there.
Right?
From the developing Yos no,
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean it's in especially like real traumatic ones,
abuse and being beaten by his Stepdad and a bunch of fucked up shit that was
just haunting him.
But he,
you know,
it helps you to come to terms with that.
Especially the ILS because it's longer.
I felt like the first time I did Iowaska property with a Shaman,
I felt like I was a different person.
The next day I felt it was like for 10 20 years or fucking therapy or something
and just a lot of stuff at work time in my mind,
I could even see other people's point of view on things and that I couldn't see
before.
And that's huge.
Right?
See other people's point of view,
especially a guy like you who so determined and goal oriented and just cut out
all the bullshit and get it done.
It can be a little insensitive to other people's feelings around it cause it's
just like
nothing
my way.
That's a male thing in particular anyway.
Right.
And then,
and it's like steroids and bodybuilding and intensity and competition and then
being the best,
arguably the best ever,
and just fucking grinding every day.
My son time,
yeah,
a couple of weeks ago he's was like that you don't see yourself as other people
see you.
So what do you mean?
He said,
I remember when I was a kid as first of all the size,
you know,
it was fucking huge,
but it's your persona.
You might've said to me something very like normal,
like,
uh,
you know,
whatever you,
what are you doing with a dog?
Like,
just something normal.
And he said,
no,
I'd be like,
because just your,
your,
your presence made me feel like that.
You know,
Brian,
that's gotta be weird.
You're a little tiny kid and your dad's a gorilla.
Yeah.
I remember he did a,
uh,
it's a kickboxing,
right?
So he got his black belt when it was about 11 or something like that.
And that was my thing.
I used to take into kickboxing and pick him up and he's like,
Dad,
can you just,
can you wait outside?
I'm like,
what do you mean you want me to come in and be like,
can you just wait outside?
I like don't want it to come.
It's like,
yeah,
but everyone's like freaking out and looking at you.
Well,
it's gotta be nice though.
I know.
I'm fucking coming inside man.
Semi anonymous in crowds now.
Yeah.
Unless someone's a hardcore bodybuilding fan.
Well,
there's the thing,
uh,
not necessarily slow because,
because of the interviews I did on London Real,
um,
and I talked about ios gear and DMT and spirituality in reality and all this
stuff.
I get so many people coming up to me like,
then they're not from the gym.
I get housewives that young kids,
like,
it's almost like you're the guy from London real.
You're the guy that I was.
So I got whole bunch of other people that appreciate what I'm saying about
spirituality,
about reality and life.
And they're like,
fuck man.
What'd you said?
That really helped me.
And so I got so many letters and emails and stuff to people,
you know,
like they just took something away from what I was saying.
So,
I mean that's,
that's really why I do these interviews.
It's just trying to help the whole general vibe and the,
you know,
put it out there and uh,
there's a whole consciousness awakening and revolution going on now and I'm just
want to push some dominoes,
you know,
and like create that effect.
And then,
you know,
if you touch one person,
they touch somebody else and it's like,
you know,
the butterfly wings flap here and the other side of the world was uh,
yeah,
it really ami or something.
It does seem to be working in that,
in that regard.
Right?
It is,
it is the time,
man.
The time is so many people that are more aware now than like 20 years ago
isn't it kind of like mean there's parallels to bodybuilding,
right?
It Net,
when Arnold first started doing it,
there was very little information,
Farley and you guys got to see what they did and build upon that and more
information came out.
And now because of the Internet,
there's so much information,
too much information,
more aware,
more of what it's all about.
Well with Psychedelics,
I mean 2030 years ago,
there's so much ignorance and so little understanding of,
and also so little understanding,
especially when it comes to something as extreme as Dmt,
there's still a giant percentage of our population doesn't even know what it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
they should all take it,
especially the fucking politicians.
I'd like to get those politicians,
man,
I'm fucking get them in a room and forced them to take DMT and then see how
they're going to behave afterwards,
how they're going to look at the world and treat people after they've had that
experience.
I don't,
I don't think it can be,
uh,
you know,
so self centered and on feeling as most of them are after you've had that
experience.
I think that any breakthrough psychedelic experience,
whether it's silicide been,
or LSD or DMT,
there's all pretty much,
you know,
ego dissolving roads to the same place.
Well,
Terrence Mckenna used to say the DMT is the center of the Mandola.
The way I described DMT is it's like mushrooms times a million plus aliens.
Yeah.
That it just seems so titanic,
Lee bazaar that there's like,
I've tried to describe it to be bold,
but I always say,
look,
I'm going to tell her how to do it.
I'm going to give you some bullshit words.
ECON,
it's no way.
I don't have the words to put it into words,
you know,
you can attempt to do,
I went to this place where it's not a place,
but,
right.
I don't have the word for it.
The places everywhere,
uh,
is like,
and this color is this numbers,
shapes and people think things and there's just like is old one fucking thing.
And what I noticed is like my breath was connected to it.
I don't know how it happened.
I was in the trip and I went like that and the whole thing moved is I really let
me try this then.
And then the whole thing moves.
And then there was music playing and the music was part of the thing as well.
Like the thing,
I don't even know what to call it,
that thing,
the place I don't have it.
Do you know,
we played a bunch of,
uh,
these,
showman eco rose and the Shama,
cause this is the last time I did it and the sham and rose like literally made
the DMT images dance.
Yeah.
Like they had figured out a way with these sounds and songs to integrate these
beats into DMT trips.
And as you would take these trips,
these shamans had figured out the right sounds and songs and how to make the
trip more intense and sort of guide it in a strange way.
What I had with um,
with a shaman,
with the Ios [inaudible],
he comes around and he sings,
he's a Kairos and this like change his tone and then it goes deeper base in his
chest and it's like,
it's,
it becomes part of it,
you know,
and I was even moving and voluntarily I was my arms,
it's going up,
my body was moving and it's like,
I'm not doing this.
I don't even know how it's happening.
It's like somebody is picking my arms up in the movement.
I was,
you know,
started dancing around with this becoming part of this rhythm.
Wow.
I had experienced once one of the first times ever did DMT where I saw the
difference between negative and positive thinking.
Like I started thinking negative and there was all this like black and dark
green,
these uh,
threatening shapes and colors.
And then something recognized what was going on in my brain that these shapes
and images were connected to negative thinking.
And I relaxed in the shapes,
kind of like settled down.
And then I started thinking positive.
Like I heard all these like expressions of love,
but like you're hearing it but you're not really hearing it.
It's like the thoughts are getting into your head.
Like someone's trying to say it without using words.
And then I started thinking positive and from those dark images blossomed.
He's like beautiful,
like geometric flowers and colors and impossibly spectacularly beautiful images.
And I was like,
oh.
And I,
I,
I've recognized in my mind there is an actual thing that happens when you think
negatively and an actual,
it's not just some sort of an abstract idea to affect the program.
They're in a program.
Yeah.
And your thoughts,
the program's coming towards you and your thoughts are going to,
and it's interacting with the program.
And that's why conflict like interpersonal conflict between people can be so
negative.
It's not just as simple as you and some person getting into an argument.
It's those dark images and those negative forces,
it becomes a part of your system.
I had exactly the same thing,
so,
but it was almost like a tunnel.
I was in this tunnel and it was the same thing.
I was like,
yeah,
all these images around and scary and everything.
And I was like,
I instinctively,
I knew it'd be very relaxed and I started laughing like fuck you and not even
real.
You're not even real.
And when I said that it went away and I just got this thing that came into my
head.
You've just been in the valley.
Um,
what's it called?
The Valley of the shadow of death.
As soon as the Lord's prayer,
I think.
Yeah,
you're though we walk through the Valley of the shadow of death.
I fear no evil because God's part aside,
I vaguely remember it from school or something,
but I got this thing and that you were there and you're in the valley of the
shadow of death and because you like fuck,
you would like,
oh,
it's not even real.
It just,
it just disappeared.
And then it went to somewhere really nice.
Wow.
Yeah.
I just wonder how much is real.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it's such a hippie thing to say like,
how much is real?
I don't know.
You know,
I've been having these thoughts a lot lately.
I'm like,
how much of,
how much of live do you manifest?
How much of life is real?
Because it's such a bullshit thing to think.
It's such a hippie thing to think in so many people that say that are so
annoying.
Yeah.
But scientists are saying the same thing now.
Quantum physicists of saying,
uh,
it was a fingers,
his name's professor guides.
I know if you're familiar with them,
professor gates.
And uh,
he said that they've broken down reality into the smallest level and it's a
computer code.
Yes.
I've seen that guy.
He's a computer code.
It's a specific computer code of Zeros and ones and it was invented in the 1940s
by somebody.
Yeah,
I've seen that guy being interviewed.
Um,
we actually talked about it with Neil degrasse Tyson and he,
I tried to get him to sort of break it down and explain,
but what it is is essentially that when you break reality down to the smallest
level,
it mimics a self correcting computer code.
Not just not just a computer code,
but a computer code that self-correcting,
which is right there.
I just had a bunch of noises that I don't even understand that,
you know,
it's just,
it's gone beyond my,
now you're getting a spirituality and science,
right.
He's coming together because the scientists are saying what spiritual masters or
the already telling us is that we live in an illusion and everything is inside,
not outside.
They were saying that thousands of years ago,
but it's real
like you have to work hard or you don't get results,
right.
Like your,
your hard fast pragmatic reality of being the best bodybuilder in the world
revolves around actual work.
Real results
in this,
in this reality and this program,
but also to do physical stuff.
Yeah,
probably there was a lot of mental shit going on there too.
Absolutely.
The work was being done,
but also there was probably a four.
It's all day.
I mean,
that's all I thought about it literally all fucking day.
So,
you know,
I had to have the physical goods to make it happen.
I could dream about being a basketball player,
old.
I probably help me because I'm not built to be a basketball player.
What those thoughts were just going out all the time.
And I was a kid in Birmingham,
industrial city in England,
and I was thinking,
I'm going to go to America and I'm going to be a bodybuilder.
And everyone around me was like,
the fuck you talking about.
Um,
so yeah,
that was,
it was those thoughts all the time.
So I think it's like a holographic program.
We're in,
what we influenced that we interact with it,
with our thoughts.
That's kind of where I'm getting that now in some way.